[Music]
let's dig into
the new book i want to do it in a
particular way
which is starting with a quote of yours
that a close friend of mine has
committed to memory now
please fact check me on this perhaps
it's abraham lincoln or oscar wilde or
one of the other
ubiquitous attributions on the internet
but but here we go
and i'm fond of this as well quote it
seems to me that the purpose of life is
to find a mode of being that is so
meaningful
that the fact that life is suffering is
no longer relevant
now i have a i have a follow-up just a
segue from that
but is that an accurate quote
well i don't know if it's an accurate
quote but it sounds like something i
probably said
accurate sentiment a a a
attributed accurately attributed all
right it seems to me that it's true
i mean it isn't necessarily the case
that you can do it
all right yeah so right it's hard to do
i mean
and that of course it's hard i suppose
in proportion to the suffering that
you're undergoing
and it isn't necessarily the case that
you can always manage it but
but but sometimes you can manage it and
and it's good if you can
so i want to uh use
your book as a
i mean prop isn't the right word a
vehicle for exploring this
uh one of the books that you often
reference
is man search for meaning by victor
frankl
sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna stop just for
a sec because i thought about some other
things
so this is partly why
i have a certain
conservative bent i suppose see
people need to search for meaning
because they get corrupted by suffering
if their life isn't meaningful that's
how it looks to me
because you can't torture an animal
forever without it lashing out
and so if your life is nothing if
there's nothing in it that speaks to you
there's still going to be suffering you
can't talk yourself out of that
and so then i see people tearing tearing
down
traditional structures let's say
or they're casual about them another
rule in this new book is
do not casually denigrate social
institutions or creative achievement
well why
social institutions well i've counseled
lots of people who were lost
and so if you came to see me and i was
your therapist
i'm very practical i'd say to you okay
well let's look at your life for a
minute
um do you have an intimate relationship
what about your family and that could be
you know married with kids or it could
be the family of your birth
your siblings and your parents and so on
how's that functioning do you have
anyone there
do you have a job or maybe a career even
if you're fortunate at least a job that
keeps body and soul together and maybe
where there's some chance of advancement
and hope um
do you know how to use your time outside
of work productively
do you take care of your mental and
physical health do you manage
the temptations drug and alcohol use and
that sort of thing do you manage those
temptations effectively
um are you educated as
are you as educated as you are
intelligent you know have you
and those are standard
those are standard patterns of activity
in the world do you have kids do you
have a wife do you or a husband do you
have a job
i mean it's mundane in some sense but
and you can look beyond all those
standard answers for meaning
but if you're overwhelmed by life
anxious and
and suffering that's a good place to
start put that together
why well the answer that is because
that's what people do
that's what people do that's the best
we've been able to manage
and so and if you don't have that
because you're a human being like other
human beings
you're going to suffer for it
and so attacks on that assaults on that
aren't that helpful
unless you have a better like i have
this friend he's an atheist
and he's wavering about this he was born
a communist he was raised in poland
and he had objected at one point to
the christmas traditions of his family
who were also atheistic and
you know he objected on the grounds of
logical coherence
why are we doing this well
don't do it well then what happens well
then you have another weekday
you lose christmas well
great it's like now you're logically
coherent wonderful
but you've lost christmas you don't want
to throw these things away
you know when i see this sometimes with
young people when they're talking about
getting married
we don't need to get married we don't
need a piece of paper it's like
really that's your that's the depth of
thought you've put into this
it's like you're not going to mark this
permanence
with conscious awareness and social
celebration and the sanction of your
community and
a beautiful ceremony that's just nothing
you let that go well what do you
what are you going to replace it with
nothing
you know you can say it's it's i don't
want to be married in a church
i don't believe in god fair enough
but good luck filling in the hole
you